[Música]
quando me chamaram pra falar aqui no
tele x campinas
eu fiquei em dúvida é sobre o que eu vou
falar de relevante para todas as pessoas
aqui que é interessante é o próximo eu
posso trazê lo e aí eu pensei bom vou
fazer uma fala executiva né vou falar do
painel bap que o primeiro painel de
consumidores afro-brasileiro uma
plataforma onde qualquer pessoa pode
participar de pesquisa de mercado ser
remunerado em dinheiro produtos e
serviços já foi empreendedores
legal né seria uma fala assim moderna
blackman e afro empreendedorismo
mas foi bom mas é preciso de uma coisa
assim que deu um pouco mais de emoção
então pensei que eu poderia compartilhar
com vocês sobre quando eu uma executiva
de negócios
fui escrevi nada despedida e escoltada
para fora do meu local de trabalho
porque não aceitaram uma identidade por
causa do meu cabelo e aí eu poderia
falar o que acontece com trabalhadores e
profissionais pretos afro brasileiros
negros e periféricos dentro dos
escritórios todos os dias
mas aí também bota x campinas o futebol
quer uma fala sem mais intelectual mas
mas descolada e poderia falar sobre o
tumblr maior black frente de todo mundo
tem um maior leque fred né que é a idéia
do negro único aquele único que
representa toda a diversidade
mas eu pensei poxa que as pessoas querem
discutir semiótica em pleno sábado e aí
bom como o evento tem como tema que tem
gente eu vou falar de mim não é só uma
pessoa vou falar um pouco de mim e aí eu
vou contar que quando eu era é criança
né e morava em um prédio eo meu prédio
tinha três elevadores dois elevadores
sociais em um elevador de serviço
o elevador de serviço ele servia pra
subir mudança para tirar o lixo subir
com o carrinho de compra que tinham os
elevadores sociais bem um dia a dor
quando tinha por volta de 15 anos uma
coisa muito diferente aconteceu em cada
um dos elevadores foram colocou foi
colocada uma
a faca que era essa cota é vedada
qualquer forma de discriminação em
virtude de raça sexo cor origem
orientação sexual e identidade de gênero
condição social idade forte presença de
deficiência ou doença não contagiosa por
contato social nos dão acesso aos
elevadores de si difícil então cada um
dos elevadores aquele condomínio ganhar
uma placa dessa e acho que é meio
confusa porque na sociedade tem muitas
leis mas a gente não vê as leis pregadas
em todos os locais então todas as vezes
que eu entrava no elevador
eu vim aquela placa e me trazer uma
certa
ficava pensando muito naquilo bem um dia
estava entrando com meu pai no prédio e
aí eu vi a mãe da minha amiga a mãe da
minha e ela estava brigando com o
porteiro com o síndico falando que ela
estava indignada com aquela placa porque
ela não queria que a babá da filha dela
subisse no mesmo elevador que ela quando
não tivesse com as crianças e que era um
absurdo aquilo que ela era moradora
tinha direito de exigir onde um em qual
dos elevadores que a babá que ficava na
casa dela cuidava dos filhos dela teria
que subir quando ela estiver sozinho eu
fiquei mais confusa ainda porque o
primeiro
toda vez que abre elevador de uma placa
proibindo a discriminação e do outro
lado uma pessoa que eu conhecia era uma
mãe de uma amiga minha
indignada com a presença daquela placa
porque ela queria todo direito de
discriminar quem entrasse no elevador e
aí eu perguntei pro meu pai eu falei
porque que ela está fazendo isso e aí
ele falou algumas pessoas sentem que são
melhores que as outras
eu era adolescente eu não tinha muita
não tinha repertório cultural para
entender aquilo mas todas as vezes que
entrava no elevador ele a placa e uma
coisa que me chama muito a atenção é a
primeira das condições pela qual alguém
não pode ser discriminado no elevador e
raça
e aí você continua até ser é cor então o
legislador ele já estava
me dando um toque do que acontecer mas
era jovem beleza
aí a vida continuou eu viajei muito
viagem muitos países tudo fora morei
fora e aí quando você está fora do
brasil você percebe que tem coisas que
só tem no brasil tem muitas coisas só
tem no brasil
aí por exemplo uma coisa que só tem no
brasil e jabuticaba
a uniflor iap linea não tem nem nome
jabuticaba em outra língua só tem no
brasil
outra coisa que só tem no brasil um
cartório privado só tem aqui não e ainda
ainda mais não só tem cartório como aqui
só tem uma coisa terrível que é
reconhecimento de firma inclusive eu até
dou uma dica protege x me chama
novamente para fazer uma fala que vai
chamar os danos sociais e psicológicos
no reconhecimento de firma na sociedade
e uma outra coisa que só tem no brasil é
você entrar no elevador e uma placa
falando que você não pode discriminar e
aí isso me intrigou por muitos anos que
será que aconteceu pra no brasil ter
essa 4 porque eu fui muito elevadores em
muitas cidades em muitos países que
nunca vi a placa e aí pra se ter uma
idéia pensa então começa lá no egito
número egito
mesmo com tânia grécia roma revolução
francesa o homem foi à lua e nenhum
desses momentos teve uma necessidade
surgiu essa lei até que em são paulo e
um século 20 uma legisladora achou
importante levar aquela viagem de 30
segundos que a gente faz um elevador e
tranqüila e vá pro levar poder é é
legislativo e criar uma lei
bom vamos falar um pouquinho como que
como que se da criação de leis na
sociedade
o primeiro tem um grupo de pessoas e aí
as pessoas começam a ter um determinado
comportamento e aí esse comportamento
gera um dano social e o legislador
amparado por leis superiores por exemplo
o direito à dignidade direito à vida
direito à segurança ele fala o país se
esse comportamento está gerando um dano
então tem que criar uma lei pra diminuir
se dando na sociedade pra é tutelada o
comportamento da pessoa para que não
tenha tanto esse dano
tá vou dar um exemplo né imagina cinto
de segurança
então todas as pessoas andam de carro e
algumas pessoas são imprudentes não são
todas alguma ação
e aí pela imprudência das pessoas começa
a acontecer muitos acidentes
o jogador fala opa eu tenho eu tenho que
garantir a segurança à vida à dignidade
das pessoas
eu vou criar uma lei falando que as
pessoas devem usar o cinto de segurança
para diminuir o dano causado pelo
comportamento de alguns no trânsito faz
sentido e assim tem muitas outras
línguas cidade bem e aí eu fiquei
pensando o que será que aconteceu no
brasil
no brasil o que acontecia tanto no
o de uma legisladora chamada aldaíza
sposati se sentar e escrever uma lei
falando que é proibido discriminar no
elevador e mais no terceiro parágrafo
diz todos os elevadores têm que ter essa
placa falando que não pode discriminar
no elevador
bem essa é historiadora alda esposa ti
ela mora em são paulo ela é uma
professora da puc eu tentei falar com
ela mas não consegui infelizmente porém
uma rápida busca na internet mostra por
que que ela criou essa lei porque
continua acontecendo e se ela não
tivesse criado uma lei falando pessoas
não discriminem no elevador
essa não seria uma não seria notícia
seria normal discriminar as pessoas
elevador e aí lembrei também da mãe da
minha amiga eu fiquei imaginando quantas
vezes ela discrimina alguém
quantas vezes ela falou pra babá da
filha dela que ficava o dia inteiro com
os filhos dela do amor cuidava cuidava
da casa de que quando ela estiver
sozinha ela não poderia pegar aquele
elevador
e quantas vezes também ela viu um
trabalhador entrou no elevador e falou
esse elevador não é pra você você tem
que pegar um outro bem eu não preciso
falar que a mãe da minha amiga uma
mulher branca a minha amiga era uma
menina branca e que a babá era uma moça
preta assim como eu e fiquei pensando
que lembra que o legislador
de cara ele já fala é proibido
discriminar em virtude de raça e cor
então hoje a mensagem que quero deixar
para vocês é não esperem a lei
vocês são os que têm os melhores
empregos estudam nas melhores
universidades
vocês são os donos dos apartamentos que
tem elevador vocês são os donos das
escolas e é deus comportamentos de
pessoas que têm poder na sociedade
também que nasce a lei não esperem a lei
para ter empatia para ter respeito pra
incluir aí pra mas há que respeitar em
aceitarem a existência do outro mesmo
que seja
em uma corrida numa subida de 30
segundos
então hoje em campinas na cidade
a última cidade do último país a abolir
a escravidão campinas foi a última
cidade do último país a mulher era
escravidão eu digo brancos não esperem a
lei ajam agora é isso